Hello. Hello. Hello. How's it going, guys? How are we doing today?
Oh my god, I left my music really loud. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on. Hello. Hello. Hello, guys. Look, Kelly's here. Look, it's
Kelly. Oh, I'm here. I'm alive. I didn't leave. Wow. Who knew?
Oh, everybody. Okay, it is locked. Wow. Guys, I uh So, I said
I'd start stream and then I ended up getting a phone call and
I have to make a phone call. So, I'm going to be right back.
You guys are with Kelly for
could be two minutes. Could be a 100 minutes. I actually have
no idea.
Be the rest of your life. Awesome sauce. Thank you for the five
gifted. Let's go. Let's go. Thank you very much, guys. I'm going
to kill myself. Don't do that in a video game. Kelly doesn't
mean that. Don't do that. No. No. No. No. No. I didn't. I was
reading out of chat. I wasn't saying I'm going to, but yes. Uh-huh.
Uh-huh. Uh-huh. Uh-huh. I also
Oh, what is that? Mew Crusty with a gifted sub. Thank you very
much, Meatwag Crusty. Okay, we will or I will be right back.
And I uh brutal comment second. Really wish you hadn't said that,
but it's okay. I'm going to go make this phone call and I will
be right back. And then I will Yeah, we're going to do stuff.
I think we're just going to do Yeah, we're going to cover basically
this stuff. I said I wasn't going to comment. I think I will
comment. I'll go through and I'll comment. I'll respond to some
stuff and then I don't have much of a choice. Let's be right
back. Yeah, we'll see where it goes. So anyway, all right. I
uh Nick static, you're wrong, but we'll talk about it when I
get back. Okay, so I'll be right back. Kelly has the helm. Yeah,
I will. Like I said, I will be right back. You should be scared.
Okay, so you guys, you need to chill. Second, like so much. Why
did Ch backstab you? Uh, I think Chud's criticisms are
fine for the most part and we can we can literally talk about
it. Yeah. I It's literally Chud's job. Uh, the way you have to
look at it with all of this stuff is Chud is going to give you
what he like what his brutally honest opinion is. And when he
does that, uh, sorry, when he does that, he is thinking of like
going forward. Like basically, if uh, if something bad were to
happen, he looks bad if he doesn't, um, you know, express his
full opinion right now. So, I don't I don't see it as a backstab.
I don't see Chut as like a problem. Anyway, he has to give his
opinion. Okay. Yeah. All right. Good luck with the phone call.
Yeah. I'll be right back. Okay. Bye-bye, guys. Will he ask Chat
GP if the Minecraft gameplay is adequate? Why do I need to ask
chat GPT for that? Why the facecam? Oh, because Destiny called
me fat again today. So, was it today or yesterday? I don't remember
what day it is. I'm just here to remind everyone I'm not fat.
Aside from the Okay, see fats. So, happy America day. Oh, is
it the Oh, it's the 4th of July. Losers would have been better
off with us. I'm just saying. Cringe. Imagine, imagine teaming
up with the French and the Spanish. Boo. Boo. Lame. Cringe. The
UK. Jesus Christ. Well, at least you can be angry about something
else, I guess. Jesus. Oh, everyone's so seething. Funny. But
no, I mean, it's good that we don't have to take responsibility
for the things you did anymore. So, it's not so bad. Oh, it's
easy. No, that is gross. Don't use that word. But, all right,
let's start with questions. I guess maybe stick to things that
make sense for me to answer. I don't know. Am I mad at justical?
No. But I also like knew that this was happening, right? And
it's like sometimes I mean I did not give any advice by the way.
I found out when stuff was happening. You can't give people advice
when it comes to like relationships anyway. They're just going
to do it or they won't. But what I will say is um neither party
is lying. The reason they seem like they're saying different
things is just because of their perspective. So like Cherry's
not wrong. Just not wrong. I mean, one thing Cherry is is like
she's being treated very badly by other people obviously. Like
the stuff that Destiny did is awful. And so that makes her well
just also paranoid, but Cherry is too for like good reasons,
right? And that paranoia kind of colors the things that they
do and they say, especially when they're not necessarily emotionally
stable. Um, and they both do it. They both have emotionally unstable
moments. Just being just as emotionally unstable on a number
of occasions. Yeah. I mean, um, I can't speak about Cherry. I
think for anything that's happening with Cherry right now, I'll
probably leave it to just what he decides to say. It is embarrassing.
Yeah, of course. It's like it's it's embarrassing. And um I did
say to just call like I think it's going to be better for uh
if it's coming from you guys that you're dating rather than it
coming out like this, right? When she got upset. Um and it's
also normal for Cherry to want to tell other people. Um and she
did tell me. It wasn't just that told me it was Cherry. I'm not
sure with Queen who told him. Um but I think that that wasn't
quite enough. I think she wanted more people to know than just
like two, which is understandable. You should be cancelled. Kind
of cringe, dude. What? For dating? You should be cancelled for
dating. Something I will say is like just treats Cherry like
a human being. He's not treating her like a tool. I don't know.
I mean, if you take a literal interpretation of what Cherry's
upset about, maybe, but it doesn't make sense otherwise. It's
he's not like someone that engages in like um what's the word?
Like open relationships and like just around and stuff. So if
he is with someone, it's cuz he likes them. But I think he doesn't
really show uh he doesn't really show much of his personality
outside of what you get on the stream. So it would be maybe kind
of um what's the word? Maybe it's a shock to like people that
he has his moments or whatever. I don't know. But I it's not
a shock to me. Most men in this community are probably more emotionally
unstable than the women because the women usually have at least
a diagnosis and they've like tried and they're trying and they're
like figuring out. All the men don't have any clue what's going
on with themselves or anyone around them. Useless all of you.
So, you know, whatever. No. People are unstable here. It's an
online community. True,
true, true. I feel like I just said the most obvious thing of
all time, but whatever. Women usually have a diagnosis. Yes.
Just cuz you don't have a diagnosis doesn't mean you're better
off, right? I thought the odds would be better that Kelly would
be dating Jessica. Based on what? Based on what? Someone like
tagged me and said it was like to President Sunday's message
in spicy chat. I can't remember what he said, but it's like people
did this when I helped Kantos as well. So I'm like, yeah, I got
withistical after I ran away from Kantos when I was nearly being
beheaded. I can't remember what I said. Something along this
line. It's like obviously not. I obviously have absolutely no
interest in men at all and especially not these men. No offense.
Like hello. It's like I had a crush on one person who's like
in my real life and that lasted like for 5 minutes until they
annoyed me and then I was like, oh yeah, I don't like people.
Never mind. Does this mean Jessicles can stop pretending to like
slash tolerate these people now? What do you mean G old? I don't
know what. Who are these people? I thought you've been in relationships.
Yeah, like two. The last one was forever ago. Don't start spamming
me with you people or I'll get tilted. And don't at me. I just
I can pay attention to the stream chat. I'm not paying attention
to the rest of you. I'm not posting in the Discord. You can at
me all you like. I'm not paying attention. Kelly is a lesbian.
I I am, but I really I'm not I'm by myself. I don't really I
don't do anything. All right. People me off too quickly for me
to bother. It's time to admit you appreciate us. Um
uh maybe. Do I I appreciate you? I'll have to think about it.
Are you upset at the situation? I mean, I feel bad for Cherry,
but what what do you mean? What else would I have to be upset
about? Keep in mind, so I've like been speaking to Cherry the
entire time as well, right? So, absolutely none of this is a
surprise, which is why people have been like losing their minds
that I was responding to some comments in my Discord, right?
Because people were speculating that just is like this cold,
calculated, manipulative
person that's like taking advantage of someone with BPD. And
I'm like, no, no, not at all. He just likes her and is about
as emotionally unstable, maybe worse. It's just like not true
because otherwise that would look bad on me and Quimman. Who
knew? Because it would seem like we're supporting a sociopath
when in reality at least I was speaking to Cherry as much as
maybe more so about these things. I I don't know. Hard to say.
Well, the Dr. K comment had nothing to do with my era of being
round. like when he when that stuff like leaked, right? It didn't
really have much to do with me. So like in January, just a reminder,
just was still being very hostile to me. Like he gave me for
not being empathetic to Destiny at one point in the middle of
January, right? And it wasn't until sort of later on in February
I was sort of trying to help because, you know, Cherry had left.
He was dealing with a lot of things. So, like when I was saying
he was being emotional in this time, it wasn't just because Cherry
had left. It was like dealing with all of the negative effects
of taking the side of the women, which comes with like DG harassing
you, Destiny thinking it would be cool to like send death threats,
you know, like people trying to dox you. It's like um and then
he had some Yeah, maybe he'll talk about it, but other stuff
in his life that doesn't have anything to do with Cherry as well.
So, it was just like it was um probably was like overwhelmed,
right? So, it's like a lot. You'd have to be overwhelmed to think,
"Oh, yeah. Let's talk to Kelly Jean as my someone I was saying
I hate two weeks ago, right? It's like I did my best considering,
right?" So, I would be up at like 3:00 a.m. having the most torturous
VC calls from my bed while I'm just like wishing I was dead.
But like I'm also not great at like uh what's the word? Like
pep talks and things like this. I'm I'd rather just tell someone
what I think. I'm not really good at being like, "Oh, you'll
be okay." Like, it just comes off kind of awkward when I'm saying
it. But yeah, he catastrophizes things a lot. Would you like
to be my artists should not be anyone's? We have a like fundamentally
probably not ideal. Where are my eyebrows? I didn't bother drawing
them in. I don't have much makeup on cuz I'm shiny. I got like
my can of water here because I'm spraying myself whenever I get
hot. It's just gonna like if I put eyebrows on it's they're going
to melt down my face as soon as I spray water on myself. Hello.
We're back. You're right. Welcome back. Welcome. Welcome. Welcome
back to me. Oh, hey. Okay. All right. I don't know what you're
talking about. I have no idea what you're talking about with
Kelly. So guys, I I'm back, but I don't know what I don't know
where you guys were going. Jay's not going to come to the subreddit
only. You are not funny. I see all of the stuff on the subreddit
that you posted where you're like, "Oh, blah blah blah." You're
doing like clickbait titles. You're not funny with your little
alt account there. You're not funny. You're not funny.
Nothing else. Just I want you to know you're not funny. At least
said you're mentally unwell and it was a chore to talk to you.
Well, I said something similar to that to you at the time. It's
not right. It's fine. All right. We all go through those periods.
That's the point of having friends, isn't it? That they're a
chore sometimes because you get to be a chore to them sometimes.
I've yet to like redeem my chore card, but I'm sure I will at
some point. When I when I talk about the pit, like putting my
emotions in the pit, I just mean I DM them to Kelly directly
and then Kelly doesn't care. I wish it's more like a three-hour
VC call. Oh, wait. Everybody just realized Hold on. Everybody
just realized it. Oh my god. Oh my god. Kelly just admitted I'm
her friend. Kelly just admitted I'm her friend. Well, you think
that, so I'm being kind. She just admitted it. She just said
it. She just said it. She just said it. She can't No takebacks.
No takebacks on that run.
In a video game. Lame. I don't like I have to be nice, but I
don't. So, like what I've noticed is everyone's like dumping
on you for the same things. They're kind of nonsensical.
And if anyone knows me, I don't like the dog piles. if someone's
being dogpiled, I will simply take their side and fight from
their position out of I don't know because I just do. But also
like um the majority of the things that people have said uh they're
kind of meaningless dribble. It's just like oh he was compromised
and he was biased but you said you were biased from the start
because you're like Cher's my friend and you're like the most
biased there is. I don't it was obvious. So I don't know what
difference it makes. Well, I don't know if anybody remembers
that West call where he was like, "You're mad cuz your friend
got like this happened to your friend." I'm like, "Yeah, I'm
mad because my Yeah, I'm extra I'm absolutely extra mad because
this happened to like somebody I care about a lot." Uh, by the
way, I don't know how we're going to talk through this necessarily.
I don't have like a script or anything or a schedule. Um, but
timeline wise,
uh, timeline wise, Cherry and I literally weren't speaking in
the leadup to this. Uh, basically what broke like uh more or
less no contact was her messaging me that a recording had been
made of her and she'd been notified of this. So we basically
hadn't been talking. She hadn't been on stream in like a month
and a half or something. Month, month and a half. And she messaged
me saying like, "Hey, um, she messaged me saying like, "Hey,
I just found out about this. I don't like I don't know other
people to talk to about this. Like I or whatever. Like you're
a person I trust." Okay. Just to be specific, you hadn't been
talking, but I had I had been on a stream with her in earlier
January. So, I think it's more like she maybe disappeared for
a few weeks rather than a month and a half. I'm not sure because
there were like
Yeah, I think there was at least one stream. It wasn't the New
Year's Eve stream, but maybe one after and then something. I
think it was like that. I mean, I might be wrong, but I do know
that you hadn't been talking for some period before then. And
I don't remember when she left the second time either. Was that
in February? It must have been, right? Um, yeah, I was in midFebruary,
late February, somewhere in there. Something like this. To be
fair, it's difficult to remember the timeline specifically a
little bit, but it's like it's uh it's fine. So, anyway,
can I say this thing? I'm just going to type it to you.
Uh, Splitty Lit that like that was me in uh 2023. I think there's
a very different behavior I'm critiquing there, but I don't want
to focus on that in this stream. Um, if you guys want to talk
about it, like if you guys do want to talk about it, we can talk
about that, right? But I think probably people want to get more
like other analysis, right? Do I have like uh mods? By the way,
if people are just like here to whine or complain, you can feel
free to just perma banan. There are going to be like a lot of
um DJers here. So, you just perma banan the accounts that are
just like only uh by the way also if you have if you have actual
criticisms there will be a portion where you can call in with
like actual criticisms. So, yeah. I just sent you a message.
Can I say that or is that maybe not? I don't know what's awkward
or what what um
Okay, no worries. So, basically, see like I'm checking. Don't
do not ban Lumpy Willy. Do not ban Lumpy Willy. Do not ban Lumpy
Willy. Sorry. I just had to say that in case somebody thought
that was uh let him say stuff. You couldn't just let him let
him say I think you just wanted to say lumpy Willie like three
times in my ear. No, I'm just I It's bad luck to ban yump lumpy
Willy. Okay. Can't can't ban that guy. Um
yeah, I don't know. [__] I didn't I literally didn't
write a script for this. Uh probably the conflict of interest
thing that Kelly was talking about. That was like the biggest
thing to me that like I wanted to address. If people have perceptions
about um what what should I say on this? I think you should support
Cherry. I think if Cherry says this, you should be suspect, right?
You should be extra vigilant towards like my actions. Like Cherry
is uh Cherry made some posts. I don't think you should uh I don't
think you should dismiss them, okay? And you can be suspicious
of me. I would say probably my criticisms of other people, if
you want to call me out for being a hypocrite, I think my criticisms
of other people have to do with patterns of behavior or like
imminent action, right? So, I don't think the hypocrisy angle
really hits for me in any way at all. I don't think the conflict
of interest thing hits for me in any way at all. If you want
to say that I made decisions that probably weren't in my economic
or financial interest, I think you're that's fine. I think that's
probably true. Um, Cherry and I were together. Uh we did not
have a period of like e dating. Um basically I didn't want to
do anything like on Discord or on the internet. I said like if
we're going to do this then like you should we should meet up
in person.
She flew here. We hung out for a couple weeks.
Good. Uh cares if there was a bit of e dating anyway. That's
such a weird thing to care about. Well, I just I just don't take
it like seriously. So anyway,
My my understanding is there was a separation there already.
I don't think she was cheating on somebody. I don't think that's
what it was. Like I I'm pretty confident that's not what it was.
Um
now I think probably the criticism that I heard that hit the
the hardest or the best was like, "Oh well, even if it only started
at the beginning of June, then probably there was a relationship
like building before that." Um and this ties into the conflict
of interest thing, but realistically, right?
I think that conflict was already baked in to me being like close
friends with Cherry and having streamed with her, you know, eight
hours a day, six days a week for months and months and months
before that, right? We were already friends. Uh I said as much
when we came up with all of this stuff, right? That like we're
friends. I'm very I'm extra upset. I'm way more upset because
we're friends. So there's Yeah, I guess you could say the conflict
of interest is there, but it was advertised. If the conflict
of interest is tangible towards any criticism, then just give
me the take you disagree with and you can come on and explain
how my conflict of interest led to me having that take. Right.
If I can totally defend any one of those takes, then I don't
know I don't know what we're talking about here. Would you apologize
to Tom? No. None of my criticisms of Tom were this. But I just
I feel like it's obvious. Also, I'm fairly sure that I gave you
at the time, right? Because I obviously I cared from the moment.
I knew that Molina's stuff had been like treated imply and I
me and Jical had arguments about that because he felt like oh
well I don't know if that's like you know non-consensual or not
and that was before we knew like Pixie stuff even right so I
just yeah I I thought everyone kind of knew that things changed
when it happened to Cherry because just call out a bias cuz he
cared more about her as a friend and he didn't really know everyone
I just thought that was obvious. So maybe it wasn't so obvious.
I'm not sure sure who to whom it wasn't. At Jtock, will you admit
that you have dumb taste in women? Sorry, I have to answer this
question. Excuse me. No, I literally don't regret I don't regret
forming that relationship. I don't regret being friends with
this person. I don't regret trying to date this person. I don't
regret any of that. No. That's like the big difference here is
I'm not doing this to like goon. I'm not doing this to like just
get my rocks off. I don't actually regret any of it. I don't
regret liking this person. I don't regret being close to this
person at all. Um, and I think the people who have like intimated
otherwise are gross. Yeah, I don't I do think you should have
just bit the bullet and told people though. I will kind of say
that and I did say that at the time, right? And I I kind of get
why you're being reserved cuz you don't want things to go badly
or whatever. But yeah, but that's like a hindsight thing, I guess.
Uh I will I will say my so I said absolutely we should tell people
after the first time we're together and if as soon as you come
for your second time if there's a second time then we should
tell people if it's just like oh this doesn't work at all we
can't stand each other then I don't think we should tell anybody
I think we should just let it go away and that's dumb just FYI
that was stupid apparently that was stupid yes it what do you
mean apparently it was it was just I thought that was reasonable
but I think it is perhaps not the best decision. I said I thought
that was reasonable. Yeah. Um it is what it is. That's very stupid.
Yes. Okay. But that's like the biggest criticism I have. So you're
all in. Uh I was not all in on Cher's thing without much info
out there. That's the that is where like the major mistake has
happened. Yeah. I was not all in on that without info. Um there
were like significant discussions before that. Right. They want
to know about the Cherry said that you would delete things if
it went public. Is this like some kind of uh overeotmotional
thing you said cuz you've done you I would have to I would just
have to let her speak on that. I would just have to let her speak
on that. What I will say is Jessica told me to delete my Discord
before. So he gets into like this like he says things that I
don't think he really means. I just think you get mad and like
say because you're also apparently apparently nobody knew he
said you stupid [__]
shut up you stupid [__] So
why did Cherry post a screenshot from your phone perspective
because I sent her an email of my texts. God damn it. I didn't
want to explain any of that. She she had me blocked so she didn't
see those texts but I sent her an email saying here are the texts
that you missed. It's embarrassing. It's embarrassing that I
Yeah, that's embarrassing. Okay. It's embarrassing to have that
leaked. No, it's embarrassing that you were emailing the person
you're dating. That's just bizarre behavior. I really should
have said that in the time. These guys would sit there and block
each other and email each other. Like, who does this last my
last email
is so dumb?
And is also just a bad blocker in
Thank you for the help as well. If you send me more than 15 messages
in a row, I will block you. That That's not even why you blocked
me. I sent you no messages and you blocked me when I was still
sitting on a VC in a stream with you and I didn't notice till
the next day. Okay. A little [__] Are you aware of
she? Um, she's safe. Poop my pants off. She's safe. Just a confirmed.
How did you Okay. How do you get out of this situation? I feel
like this is very much the opposite of
people who say that are just not being reasonable. I don't even
know if I'd really address it. I just don't know if I'd address
it at all.
Um, also I find it weird that people So, um, another criticism
I heard was, "Oh, you shouldn't date somebody who's like the
subject of your coverage." And it's like, well, one, I'd basically
like uh I and correct me if I'm wrong, I basically moved on from
covering Cherry in like large part um somewhere around the beginning
of June, maybe even before that, right? But beyond that, I was
covering stuff against Destiny, I guess. And you could argue
that yeah, there's a conflict there, but like realistically,
wouldn't the conflict be that this guy's like actually calling
for my death? Wouldn't the conflict actually be that this guy
is like maliciously lying about me and all of my friends? Yeah,
there was a point where we started being more careful when it
was stuff that was related to Cherry and Destiny specifically
and we wouldn't speak about it cuz Jessica basically doesn't
message me very often to be on stream, but he would every time
it's about to happen
pig my ears donated $3. Don't get mad at me, but are you anticipating
a trial of JSTLK event? Um, no. I don't think so. Well, maybe
we could do that at some point. And trial for what? being a Yeah.
The the unfortunate thing here is we've got like a real overlap
of uh concerns and if people No, no, no. Don't ban that. That
guy's fine. That guy's fine. That guy's fine. I think that guy's
totally fine. Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, this guy asked a good
question, actually. Are you going to address the mentally ill
woman equals How in the world could people possibly think that's
my take? When I streamed with somebody consistently who had BPD
and had a husband, do you think that I was friends with this
person and had an amicable relationship with them while saying
that their husband was committing any time they were with them?
Do we believe that that could possibly be the case? Do we believe
that? Uh, do we believe that that could possibly be the case?
That is such an insane take. Somebody give me anything approaching
that. Someone give me a clip that literally that is just totally
made up from Destiny. And this is the one time I will actually
call anybody out is this one Willie Mack tweet was maybe the
like even for Willie Mack this was an exceptionally
low IQ statement. Wait, wait, wait. Where is it? Where is it?
Where is it? Where is it? You know who did say it? Cuz I have
no clue. And to think this was the same guy JTO who spent the
last year saying having mentally ill people equals. Never said
that. Never even intimated that. Right. I'm not going to go too
much into these guys, but this is maybe the lowest IQ take Willie
Max ever had, and he doesn't have high IQ takes. Like, it is
so embarrassing. I've never once said this. I've never once thought
this. The best. I have no idea. Like the best I can think is
like maybe maybe in one of our joking sessions like I think maybe
with the uh I remember the closest we ever got to this was maybe
the Keemstar thing where I think I think Queen might have said
something like oh she's like too consent right anyway
um I think Dioro said something similar about me
and then he ran away because I kept calling him fat. So, uh,
have you ever looked at Diorio? Like, he looks like Cartman if
like he came to life. I just Yes. Hold on. I I do want to point
out how ironic and hilarious it is that the main criticism we
had of Willie Mack going into that Queen debate was, "Hey, you're
like replatforming totally salacious from Destiny without questioning
it at all." And to top it off at the very end of the day, he's
like, "Hey, everything Destiny is saying here is true." without
evaluating it, without looking for any facts, he just goes, "Whatever
Destiny said is true." Because that's like actually his compass
for evaluating facts in the world. Whatever Dusty said is true.
That's He must be in such a tough spot. That's very embarrassing
for him. Yeah. I can't do anything about this Willie Mistical
beef now. I give up. They're just going to constantly each other.
I just Whoever's funniest wins, I guess. I have Kelly's like
face off. Um my face off. But yeah, sorry. I had you I had you
up at the top. I probably left you in a weird spot while we were
doing stuff. Oh, I'm not even showing the Willie tweet. Hold
on. There's the Willy tweet right there. Yeah. Everything Destiny
is saying here is true. That's like I never said that. I've literally
never said that. That is just totally made up. Did anyone say
it? That's what I'm baffled by cuz I wouldn't have said it. So,
I don't think it's my fault either. I'm like, was it my fault?
I hope not. Did Queenman say anything like this? I don't think
so. I think there was a time where we where he we talked joked
about somebody being too consent in any capacity. I just want
somebody to post that was talking about me not in like a way
just like she's too to be like allowed on the internet. I don't.
So, yeah. Sure. Sure. Sure. I think this has something to do
with like a conflation of talking about a pattern of behavior
over time and like like if you consistently if you consistently
target people who have some some defect, right? Obviously, then
people start to see, oh, well, maybe you're doing something bad
here, right? Yeah. I mean, I'll repeat what I said before, and
that's my general ethos is like people with mental illness are
allowed to date as well. Like, the fact that they're being treated
like a secondass citizen is bizarre, especially because of how
common like a lot of mental illness is. It's like you'd be saying
like I don't know what 40% of the population is not allowed to
date. I don't No, they should be sterilized and institutionalized.
Okay. It's just weird. I'm uh so I'm just looking. Um Kuryoko
says pursuing Cherry. So I need to answer this from Kuryoko because
he is a longtime fan of the stream. Okay. He's here all the time
and he's had some actual criticisms. Pursuing Cherry during a
time when she's sensitive to intimacy because of Destiny's betrayal
of her probably was not a good idea, especially knowing that
she is BPD. I do agree that there are a lot of competing concerns
there and I there probably is a real criticism there. I did consider
this obviously. Um, it is something I was concerned about. I
don't think that I can totally rule out that being a valid thing
to do just because she was uh upset about Destiny. I would say
also that immediately in the aftermath, there was nothing like
that. Um, and then we in a period of like not talking between
February and like uh May, I want to say no, I I need to say something
because the way that people talk about this, they treat you like
you must be a rational, logical robot that kind of knows that
you're just as as everyone else when they have feelings for someone,
right? Like you made stupid decisions because it was cloud your
judgment is clouded by the fact you like someone and that's like
the most normal thing on the planet. But they're all like, "Ah,
Jessica should have known he was doing something. Why would he
have known he was doing anything wrong or that there really was
anything wrong done?" I don't really know. It's just like a silly
thing to imply. She like I don't know. It's just strange. Sure.
Sure. It is strange. I mean, I I will say maybe that the fact
that you pay her at certain points could have been a conflict
of interest. I don't think the fact that she was just here and
dealing with their issues if if they're going to look at it as
the position of you're her boss, but I don't really think that
was the case, right? I'm like, you've never really spoken. So,
Jessica actually offered to pay me before. For some bizarre reason,
people are going around saying I'm angry that I wasn't paid.
I was like, "No, I turned it down." In the same way that I wasn't
comfortable taking money when it came to like all the Crantos'
people like having an argument about how they would split money
or whatever. I was like, I don't want to deal with this. This
is weird and stupid. I don't do things for money. I do things
cuz I feel like doing them. But I guess that could be seen as
a problem if it was like you are a her boss and you expected
certain things from her versus I don't know maybe you just split
whatever you made in the streams on those days and it wasn't
like that at all but I don't know because I don't know the specifics
of how you did things. So do you want to talk about that or not
really? Oh, we had a payment arrangement before the before this
all happened and then we didn't after and we basically for the
time like I think it was uh January to February where she was
coming on stream, we didn't like talk about that again and then
um after that we haven't spoken about that again. Yes. So it
was like after I left in like July to like the end of last year
or something basically. Yeah. Okay. That's damn valid actually.
So she wasn't being we didn't date for most of the period when
she was coming on stream. um after the New Year's thing, like
we we literally decided to officially try something uh like early
June. Yeah. Um I would I would say like those things like they're
not linear, right? Though when you have feelings, it's like I
can't say what I want to say cuz Jessica just told me no earlier.
But sometimes like you don't realize that you like someone until
you like you're like, "Oh, I do actually." So I don't that sounds
stupid, but I I don't know. Do you get what I mean? It's like
No, I ask the question from that time. I want Well, you don't
Sometimes you're not like sometimes you don't know how you feel
exactly. You can have also conflicting feelings. Sometimes you
can really hate someone because you actually like them as well.
And also sometimes you don't realize that you like someone until
they leave and they're not around anymore. And then you become
distressed by the fact that they're not there. And then you're
like, "Oh, maybe I did like this person more than I thought."
Okay. He's like, "I don't care. Shut up." That's fine. I'm just
saying these things are not that simple. Okay. Uh, okay. I'm
trying to see if we got anything else cuz yeah, I'll take chat
comments. I'm looking to see, do we got waiting room people?
Do we have people in a waiting room? We don't. You guys can probably
start filling up waiting room. And like I said, um, if I'm if
I'm just totally missing like one of the lanes of criticism,
feel free to state it out and I can uh I can talk through it
with you guys. Do you respond to your Tom Fury clip? I mean,
I would say probably right there, I literally laughed about the
fact like literally two months later once I started streaming.
So, I wasn't streaming at all when I said that and then I started
streaming and then I started doing the same thing and that was
like a perpetual meme on stream that like, oh, I just doing exactly
what like I said Tom Fury was doing. Um, it just wasn't like
a very serious thing, right? In terms of the thing with Tom Fery
was the thing that like actually made me go, "Oh, this is kind
of weird was Kelly was literally crying on a stream, right? She
was crying on Destiny's stream and then Destiny left the room
and Tom Yes. You were like actually in tears. You were like upset
at the end of a stream and he joined immediately after that.
I don't remember but I he joined immediately like like literally
Destiny exited the room and Tom like snuck right in while you
were like upset and that was more what I was laughing about.
Anyway, I don't remember this. He does. You have mentioned this
before but I don't remember this. I don't remember this. It's
like it's not even a big deal. But like that was what I was criticizing
was like that behavior of like oh they're not even done crying
yet and you're like in there. Yeah. I feel like every man in
the space has probably done this at least once. So they're all
thinking uh is this bad?
It depends what you do when you're doing it. Probably. I don't
think that necessarily
going to offer some basic emotional support is always a Sure.
Sure. Sure. It like wasn't even that bad. Are you worried that
your morals or reputation are compromised?
um totally weird. I think reputationwise there will be a hit,
but it won't be a hit that's based in like reality. So, I hope
I will be able to come back from it, but I I think probably doubtless
there has to be like some kind of hit here. Um because like there's
there's just a set of circumstances that has to do some kind
of uh like some kind of hit, right? Um, I think I think there
shouldn't be probably like a significant hit, but I do understand
that more people basically it's very easy to just kind of go
like, well, I think there's like something wrong there and then
without making a criticism. If you wanted to say that I make
decisions in my personal life that risk my professional um like
my professional reputation, that's probably just accurate. Um,
if you think you can't respect my opinions because I made the
decision to like like I think one of the things one of the criticisms
was why would you date somebody who has a history of like leaking
their private interactions with people? It's like well I like
them. I don't know what to I don't know what to tell you. I like
them. Sorry. Like that I Yeah, it is what it is, man. Like yeah,
that's up. I wish that I didn't. I wish that I didn't. Okay,
but I do. What we've learned is just does in fact negotiate with
terrorists. That was a lie. I should have just threatened to
kill myself. Then you wouldn't have leaked my Jesus Christ. So
you were not dating her for a year now. That's what I learned.
Will next time. Sorry, that was an move. My bad. Uh h should
I answer this question? What did you read out? I missed it. Storming
Wind says, "Did you ask Cherry to divorce or were you unaware
of unaware all of all along?" Uh I think I just let Cherry clarify
that. I don't Oh yeah, that's probably a better better. Like
we have a I I feel like I have a strong moral principle not to
cheat. That I don't like cheating with people. Yeah. And Yeah.
I mean, you already said she didn't cheat, so that should just
be enough for people. But, you know, who cares about that? Seems
morally wrong. I'm just not a fan. Yeah. I just don't know what
that has to do with anything else. Can you go through the tweets
and just explain what is and isn't true? No. Response to those
mentioning the Anavar situation similarities. Um, so basically
I believe uh what what would be the similarities? Hold on. Similarities
and differences. Hold on. So I'm here and I'm like, "Oh, you
should believe Cherry and she says these things and obviously
like this sucks, right? This this sucks that we're going through
this, but like I think you should uh be vigilant and you should
be concerned about this and and I'm not going to leak a single
thing about Cherry or I'm not going I'm I'm not going to do anything
like that. I'm not going to threaten her. I'm not going to leak
anything. What did Destiny say when Anavore publicly What did
uh what did Destiny say when Anavir said, "Oh, I have to leak
our to show that you're lying about me to show that you're lying
that we're not together." What did Destiny say? I think Destiny's
response when somebody even mentioned leaking about him was,
"If you do that, I will leak your nudes." So again, people comparing
it to the Anavar situation when this person's like totally reprehensible,
a complete degenerate disgenic freak who threatens everybody
whenever they turn on him, even slightly. Uh yeah, if you compare
the two situations, you are actually like three IQ. You are actually
incapable of like you said horrible things about her, right?
Like in general, they would call her a stalker and like obviously
directed harassment at her, talked about her kiwi farm thread.
Like I like just never sat around like pop [__] talking
Cherry even when she hasn't been around. Like I don't how would
that be even slightly similar? Like we've always been like every
like Cherry has always been wellliked whether she was here or
not. Um I don't and we've sort of made sure that that was maintained.
I don't like I I told just to call to ban spin boy when he was
[__] talking Cherry before. Um cuz like there's like
a couple people that are just being demented. It's just beyond
that the majority of the community always liked her. Yeah. Uh
SSS I broadly believe that and have always believed that that
men and women can't really be friends. I try. I try. What about
me? I'm not really a woman. You you said you're friends with
me. I don't know if I feel the same. Oh, so if I'm not your friend,
it doesn't matter whatever I leak, does it? Shut up. Never mind.
Men and women can be friends. I lied. I just lied to you guys.
Okay. Kelly called me. Kelly called me on it. I will leak everything.
The bouncy ball pictures. Uh, I'm looking. Okay. Um, all right.
Do we want to Are we going to go through this Destiny stream
where he was complaining about this? Hold on. Is this Hold on.
Want to be clear that I'm not Just a quick quick discussion of
differences. Anna Anna also has a long history of harassing Steven,
which is obviously not good. But Destiny also treated Anna like
garbage. He not only doxed her, but he also threatened to leak
her nudes when she threatened. I might have some pics to share
if she leaks my to leaks messages between the two of them to
prove that Destiny had been lying about her. So, do you think
that uh leaking and leaking news is proportional or do you think
it's a proportional response in the way that you're reading?
Oh, look, it's Tom Fillery. We love this guy reacting to that.
I think it's about proportional. Yeah. Thanks. So, so I just
want to drive it home on this uh on this Anavore comparison.
So, Destiny not Yeah. Not only did he threaten to leak her nudes
um if she So, it's it's really subtle what's going on there and
you might miss just how like uh how disgusting it is unless you
are a uh like an observer, okay? Unless you are a a very well
experienced observer. But, Anavoir has expressed multiple times
that her reputation is very important to her, her online reputation.
She thinks the only way to fix her online reputation as a stalker
is to prove that Destiny wanted to be with her, i.e. posting
these conversations they'd had, right? Destiny said, "If you
Destiny essentially said to her, if you try to fix your reputation,
even though I know you're obsessive about it, I will further
leak nudes and and further ruin your
Uh, Kenny Joe, I'm answering questions from chat. Do you have
a question?
If you have a question that you feel I haven't answered, go ahead
and ask it.
Is Cherry coming back? Well, we'll just have to see. She's welcome
back. I think that's the important thing to see, right? Just
have to see how she feels in the future.
I just I have no idea why. Um, yeah, people are acting like I
none of your business.
Just to make the pop-up go away. Thank you, Subbox Society, for
the six months. Let's go.
Let's flip and go. Thank you very much. Appreciate it, buddy.
Okay.
Isn't just nudes? No, it is not. It is explicitly not nudes.
It is the text version of as in like, hey, I want to rub your
feet while you like sit on the couch or sit on the bed and study,
for example, would be an example of like or adjacent texts. Legally,
they're also just categorically not treated the same. Revenge
is a crime. Leaking is just embarrassing. Okay, not even similar
as an insane thing to say. Uh, Cyberdrifter, thank the 10 gifted.
Let's go. Thank you. Thank you. Uh, D Mike Mo says, "Do you still
genuinely care for her despite your messages to her?" Uh, yes.
And I don't know what it's in spite of. I don't know where the
spite is despite. Yeah, I don't know. They might be dumb and
not realize you were the side of the messages saying that you
love her because the idiots have been confused about this. So,
but I already explained that you did, but that doesn't mean they
were listening while they were here. So, uh I'm the person I'm
the person embarrassing embarrassingly I already announced this,
but yeah, I I sent her an email of my text cuz she had me blocked.
I That's the embarrassing
Uh, if I had to choose whether or not I was like uh whether or
not I leaked texts of me being or texts of me like saying I love
you and yeah, I would choose this part. I say that [__]
all the time. Shaking my head. S behavior. Yeah, I'm I don't
know. I don't know how to explain it to you guys. I like this.
I I literally just enjoy spending time with this person. I don't
know what to tell you. I I know that's shocking given we spent
like hours and hours and hours every single day for months on
end hanging out in the same space. I know that's shocking. Can't
believe you Oh, dude. Hold on. What was the joke there on on
the Queen thing? Oh, um there was like first it was me and Cherry
and then it was uh what was the other one? Oh, there was another
one. Oh, I can't remember now. Queen had to find out that like
multiple people he was close to were like that's it's unfortunate
nothing. I can't remember the joke now. There was a funny joke
there last night. We did VC for like like four hours last night.
Collins or No. Yeah, Collins. Probably. If you have like some
criticism. What I would say is you're probably due an embarrassment.
I feel like every other commentary YouTuber in the space has
had like an embarrassing thing happen at some point. At least
it wasn't like a secret only fans like Bo Black. Could have been
worse. It's I totally missed somebody. I don't know what Chad's
embarrassing thing was. Something to do with a transgender woman.
Hold on. I uh I just missed uh I missed a I got to be right back.
Give me two seconds. It's all you got. All these men cannot be
trusted to be normal. Quan hasn't had his embarrassing moment
yet. So, he's next. Let's see what is going on in Quean's private
life with his microwave that's within like 1 ft of his room.
Queen is a furry. I mean, maybe that could be it, right? Could
be it. Microwave. Yes. You can hear the microwave ding when he's
like straight. Oh, it's so funny. It's gonna be him announcing
he's dating Naserite. You know what? That would be an epic plot
twist. Can you imagine?
I love how everyone's just forgotten that Destiny randomly wears
butt plugs on stream. Well, we have forgotten and now we have
to remember. So, thanks for that. Now we all must suffer again.
It is what it is. I don't have red hair and I also don't have
I don't have blue or green eyes. They are gray. I can color drop
them on Photoshop and you will see that they are the grayest
dingy eyes of all time. But I guess people are not used to that
color so I don't It is what it is. Everyone gets it wrong. Gray
eyes are not real. They are I I could I could send a screen dropper
of my eyes. They are they are gray. They're not blue. Blue are
prettier. Um
All of my family, aside from one of my brothers, have the same
color eyes. It's like a dishwash dishwater color. Yeah. It's
like the the sea in the UK. The color gray. It's not blue. It's
just sad. It's full of plankton and a miserable like a bad stormy
day. I don't know. Okay, I'm back. Welcome back.
I don't know. I don't know if I missed anything. Did I miss anything?
Did we miss? No, probably not. Let me see here. Let me see if
we got anybody in the Discord who's uh who's calling in. Oh,
Top Bronson, I can send you a screenshot of that. Yeah, I'll
do it later. So, if you really want accurate eye color, it's
very disappointing though. It's like a slightly bluer color than
the background on kick to be honest.
That dude that was arguing. I can't really talk about it. Can't
really talk about it. Oh, Kingler.
Um, yeah. I don't know if it's worth talking to him. Kelly or
Lavly expressed me as a foot thing. That was Lav
confirmed it. Yeah. Also, why did everybody think? Uh because
I have Native American ancestry,
my friend. Native American ancestry. Uh also, I believe we are
promoting Zezy to admin. Zezy is going to admin. I'm doing it
officially in stream right now. Zezy has ascended to admin. Zezy
is an orange name now. Zezy is an orange name. Oh my god. I mean
Zezy is a good choice but I recommend a take and and I feel like
just always has to do the opposite of whatever I suggest. Uh
well actually in this case unfortunately um I think
you admins you donkey but we could do it with another mod as
well right since Cyclone is also uh RIP or maybe you guys can
figure that one out. Um, I have to have a think
just to call. He's like, I can't completely agree with Kelly.
I have to like half agree. No, this is already This is already
decided. This was already decided. This is already decided. Okay.
Why didn't you mention anything then? Cuz I don't listen to your
suggestions about Exactly. That's just what I just said. Yeah.
True. Why are you disagreeing with me then? He doesn't listen.
I told him a week or so before you should remove mod from Cyclone
and then he leaked the mod chat. I was like, I told you to do
this a week
He doesn't He does not listen to me at all. Hold on. I Yeah,
other people are saying, "Oh, mod this person, mod that person.
I'd mod more people, but I don't know. I don't know. I I'll have
to check in." Okay. I think we'll see. We'll see as we go. Oh,
I was going to let this guy think she has more to lose in that
scenario. Like you think that people were going to lose, but
I just don't see the huge difference between like and nudes.
Like you're leaking like personal like that somebody sent you
and like trusted you with like I this equals nude nudes equivalency
was always uh baffling here. I think that's only that's like
a stretch you could only make when you're trying to prevent somebody
speak from speaking at all costs, right? At all costs. Yeah.
Anyway, oh look, it's Jake and Psycho at the festival that they're
at. Awesome art. Awesome art. You love to see it.
was a bit of a silly argument. It was.
You used to say you would never where you eat and ate and explained
why. Can you give me an example? I think it's bad, but I didn't
say I would never. In fact, in fact, I don't know if that's true.
I think I joked that I basically only dated people from my jobs.
I think I've literally told you guys that before. I'm almost
positive I've told you that. No. Am I crazy?
Uh, by the way, I think there can be ethical lapses there, but
it just it happens to work out. You You sometimes you just date
people who are around you. Porn on What is this? Why do we want
to watch Tom being pressed over Tom's a goof? Tom's a goof, guys.
Porn on demand, bro. I don't want to I'm not going to watch Tom
right now. We're not going to go too much into Tom, but I can
I'll have it up here just in case we need something to switch
to. God, no. You love Tom 10. I hated it after like 2 days. You
wanted to go for like over a week. I'm like, this is not that
interesting. This guy is quite dull for an ex drug dealer convict.
You told us to cancel. Oh, hold on. I'm going to answer this.
Hold on. There are these logs. Hold on. Cancel me. Where did
I say this? Uh oh. What the? Don't do that. Hold on. Let me let
me find the log here itself. Where did I say this? I think it
was back in January. I need to see what I was talking about.
I said Oh, that's not it. Trying to look for this exact log and
what it was because I did say that. I do remember saying that
but I don't remember where it was. I don't see it even the I
don't know what the you're on about. Hold on. What did I say
Yeah. I mostly was making fun of Psycho for being an Eater in
this case. Oh yeah, it was me like poking at Psycho for being
an Eater, which by the way, I see. Although I do think technically
didn't happen, right? Although I do think technically it didn't
happen. Um
I say e daters must die. That was it is it is cringe. Okay. It
is cringe. But I don't think I can judge these people any anymore
at all. I just don't think I can unfortunately. If that's your
big thing, okay, the hypocrisy over e dating. If that's your
like major major major thing, you got me. You got me. You you
got me. Never call me a beginner either.
That's not true. That's literally not true at all. That's not
true at all. You think you're going to be able to call me stupid
when I can just reference this and gesture in this direction?
Yeah. Everybody's going to Kelly, think about what you're asking,
Kelly. You're asking, "Oh, everybody's going to reference this
in that direction for like the rest of time. If I can't call
people stupid, what is my stream anymore at all?" You could try.
That's going to be like everybody's response for like months
and months and months. That would be everybody's response. Maybe
you'll be less stupid.
Uhhuh. Yeah.
Okay. Destiny said Kelly is illegally claiming benefits in the
UK. What do you think? He thinks I'm like a m I don't know what
he thinks. Like somehow I'm also making up an illness that makes
me somehow be able to take over the government. I don't like
what does that mean? I don't receive anything from the government.
What am I supposed to be
I'm baffled. I'm not sure if people are aware, but PIP is very
difficult to get. And the Labor government of all governments
is for some reason making it harder. So, no. I also don't even
think it's much money. When I looked it up, it's like a few hundred
or something. Like, you can't live on it. It's dumb. I don't
That's about the type of take I would expect from Destiny. I
know. Probably ruining spoilers if you want to watch the Destiny
stream, though. We will watch that. We will watch that.
Yeah. But but first, should we pull Kingler in? Kingler has like